the Joe Rogan experience how many times
is a friend sent you a text message and
you think they're serious
yeah just joking oh yeah most of the
arguments of my life so many times I'll
send someone because I say [ __ ] up
things and techsmith's half my text
messages to my friends are anus me and
Kalin and show up psycho yeah Joey Diaz
every week three pictures of his [ __ ]
the other day you showed me his balls
for like 20 minutes
these balls are unbelievable they're
gorgeous they look like Kim Kardashian's
butt they're very rare
their butt is what is it is that just
are they fake you like you know this is
Joey Diaz this is let me know look at
that gigantic log of [ __ ] that's that's
that looks like a [ __ ] no that's just
no no no I've seen those in real life he
would leave them in the toilet for me
this isn't healthy this is not if I can
help me socio ideas with healthy first
of all notice that it's not even in the
water it's on the beach next to the
water because he's kind of big doesn't
really fit on the toilet correctly I
don't understand why this doesn't break
off why doesn't his sphincter cut it
holds it in I think his his finger the
calamari is his sphincter is loose I
think when he lets it loose it's just
like a log jam that just got released
like a they opened up a dam on the river
I just whoa [ __ ] nightmares
piece of [ __ ] so he'll send me pictures
of his [ __ ] sister where what are we
doing sister thank god he's alive
because he's one of those guys it's just
like whatever outrage the one of the
things that I used to love about going
on the road with him which is it's
tragically he's too successful Joey Diaz
is famous now so I can't really take him
on the road with me as much anymore
because he's always booked but the
beautiful thing was but he will be
working with me tonight the Comedy Store
okay the beautiful thing was when I take
him on the road he would open everybody
up like so hard they're like all the
taboos are out the window by time I go
on stage oh oh yeah that's such a
[ __ ] great smart choice before you
people like he's so funny why would you
want to follow him
like well I think that's in your head
because if you're funny you're funny
yes I mean he's definitely funnier than
me he's funny than everybody has ever
lived but he's also building shakes when
Joe's on stage he's a monster but he
also he lays the foundation that it's
everything's on the table
[Applause]